ในบทนี้จะพูดถึงกรอบแนวคิด
สำหรับการมองสภาพแวดล้อมของคอมพิวเตอร์
ที่ใช้ได้ทั้งกับแล็ปท็อปของเรา
ไปจนถึงซูเปอร์คอมพิวเตอร์
เมื่อจบบทนี้แล้ว
จะเข้าใจแนวคิดพื้นฐานเกี่ยวกับทรัพยากรคอมพิวเตอร์
และความสัมพันธ์ระหว่างทรัพยากรเหล่านั้น
แล้วทรัพยากรคอมพิวเตอร์คืออะไร พูดง่าย ๆ ก็คือ
ส่วนประกอบต่าง ๆ ที่ประกอบกันเป็นระบบคอมพิวเตอร์
จะมี CPU หรือหน่วยประมวลผลกลาง
ซึ่งประมวลผลคำสั่งส่วนใหญ่ รวมถึงหน่วยความจำ
หรือ RAM ที่เก็บข้อมูลชั่วคราว
และคำสั่งของโปรแกรม
แล้วก็มี GPU หรือหน่วยประมวลผลกราฟิก
ซึ่งออกแบบมาสำหรับการเรนเดอร์กราฟิก
แต่ยังใช้กับงานคอมพิวติ้งทั่วไปได้ด้วย
ที่ต้องการการประมวลผลแบบขนานจำนวนมาก
เช่น การจำลองทางวิทยาศาสตร์ การวิเคราะห์ข้อมูล หรือ machine learning
ทรัพยากรเหล่านี้ทำงานร่วมกันเพื่อรันโปรแกรม
และแต่ละอย่างก็มีหน่วยวัดของตัวเอง
เช่น CPU วัดด้วยจำนวน core
และความเร็วสัญญาณนาฬิกา ส่วนหน่วยความจำวัดด้วยหน่วยไบต์
ทั้ง gigabyte, megabyte และ terabyte
สำหรับแต่ละปัญหาของเรา
เราจะต้องใช้ทรัพยากรชุดหนึ่ง
เพื่อรันมัน
สำคัญมากที่ต้องคำนึงถึงทรัพยากรที่ต้องการในการรัน
ให้มีประสิทธิภาพ ตำแหน่งที่รันส่วนต่าง ๆ ของโปรแกรม
และ bandwidth ของโครงสร้างพื้นฐานที่เชื่อมต่อกัน
ล้วนมีบทบาทสำคัญ
ต่อประสิทธิภาพโดยรวม
เช่น GPU อาจคำนวณบางส่วนของโปรแกรมได้เร็ว
แต่ถ้าการโหลดโปรแกรมไปยังหน่วยความจำของ GPU
ใช้เวลานานกว่า
การใช้ CPU แทนอาจเร็วกว่า ทีนี้
มาพูดถึงการสเกลทรัพยากร classical กัน
มีสองแนวทางคือ vertical scaling
และ horizontal scaling โดย vertical scaling คือการเพิ่ม
ประสิทธิภาพของทรัพยากรเดิม
เช่น ใช้ CPU ที่แรงขึ้น หรือเพิ่มหน่วยความจำ
ภายใน node เดียว
โดย node คือหน่วยหนึ่งของ compute cluster ที่รวมทรัพยากรหลาย ๆ อย่าง
เอาไว้ด้วยกัน ส่วน horizontal scaling
คือการเพิ่มทรัพยากร
เช่น CPU หรือ GPU หลายตัว
ให้ทำงานร่วมกันบน node เดียวหรือหลาย node
ทั้งสองแนวทางมีข้อดีข้อเสียของตัวเอง
และการเลือกขึ้นอยู่กับกรณีการใช้งาน
และความต้องการเฉพาะ ลองมาดูทรัพยากรประเภทใหม่กัน
ทรัพยากร quantum ประมวลผลข้อมูลเชิง quantum
ด้วย quantum processing unit หรือ QPU โดย QPU
คือระบบทั้งหมดที่รับผิดชอบ
ในการรับชุดคำสั่ง quantum ที่ executable
หรือ quantum circuit แล้วส่งคืน
คำตอบที่แม่นยำ นั่นหมายความว่า
QPU ประกอบด้วยชิป quantum หนึ่งชิปหรือมากกว่า
เช่น IBM Quantum Heron
รวมถึงส่วนประกอบเพิ่มเติมอีกหลายอย่าง
ใน dilution refrigerator
ซึ่งล้อมรอบชิป quantum ไว้
เช่น quantum amplifier อิเล็กทรอนิกส์ควบคุม
และคอมพิวเตอร์ classical ที่จำเป็น
สำหรับงานอย่างเช่นการเก็บคำสั่ง
และ waveform ในหน่วยความจำ การสะสมผลลัพธ์
และการถอดรหัสแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดในอนาคต
โดยทั่วไปแล้ว ทรัพยากร quantum วัดกันที่
คุณภาพ เช่น layered fidelity scale
จำนวน qubit
และความเร็วอย่าง circuit layer operations per
second หรือ CLOPS วันนี้เราจะมองชิป quantum
เป็นหน่วยวัด คล้ายกับที่ระบบจัดการทรัพยากร
มองว่า GPU ไม่ใช่แค่จำนวน core
แต่เป็นหน่วยทั้งหมด แล้วการสเกลล่ะ
เหมือนกับทรัพยากร classical การสเกลทรัพยากร quantum ก็
แบ่งได้เป็น vertical
และ horizontal โดย vertical scaling
คือการเพิ่มจำนวน qubit ต่อ chiplet
หรือต่อชิป
ส่วน horizontal scaling คือการเชื่อมต่อชิปต่าง ๆ
ด้วย coupler หรือ classical interconnect
เมื่อเข้าใจนิยามพื้นฐานแล้ว
มาพูดถึงการจัดการทรัพยากรกัน
การจัดการทรัพยากรในโครงสร้างพื้นฐานคอมพิวเตอร์
หมายถึงกระบวนการวางแผน
จัดสรร และควบคุมการใช้ทรัพยากรเชิงคำนวณ
เช่น CPU หน่วยความจำ storage
และ network bandwidth เพื่อให้ใช้ทรัพยากร
ได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
ลองนึกภาพการจัดการทรัพยากร
เหมือนเกม tetris หลายมิติ ที่บล็อกแต่ละชิ้น
คือความต้องการของ job แต่ละงาน
โดยแต่ละมิติแทนหน่วยทรัพยากรหนึ่งอย่าง เป้าหมาย
คือการจัดบล็อก job เหล่านี้ให้พอดีใน cube
ของทรัพยากรทั้งหมดที่มี การจัดการทรัพยากร
เป็นงานที่ซับซ้อนมาก และแต่ละศูนย์คอมพิวเตอร์ก็ใช้
วิธีที่ต่างกันในการกำหนดค่าโครงสร้างพื้นฐาน
ให้เหมาะกับความต้องการเฉพาะของผู้ใช้
เพื่อนำแนวคิดที่เพิ่งเรียนไปใช้ เราจะใช้
Slurm ซึ่งเป็น open source software
สำหรับการจัดการทรัพยากร
เพื่อสาธิต
ผมตั้ง local setup ที่มี virtual node สามตัว
เราสามารถดูข้อมูล compute node เหล่านั้น
ได้ด้วยคำสั่ง scontrol
จะมีสอง partition หรือกลุ่ม node คือ
normal และ quantum โดย partition normal ประกอบด้วย node
ที่เข้าถึงได้เฉพาะทรัพยากร classical
และ partition quantum เข้าถึงทรัพยากร quantum ได้
ลองรัน
ตัวอย่าง hello world แบบ classical ง่าย ๆ กับ Slurm กัน
ก่อนอื่นต้องมีตัวโปรแกรม hello world เสียก่อน
นี่คือโปรแกรมของเรา ซึ่งแค่พิมพ์คำว่า hello
world ออกมา
ต่อมาต้องบอก resource manager
ว่าต้องการทรัพยากรอะไรบ้างในการรันโปรแกรมนี้
ตามที่คุยกันไว้ Slurm มีวิธีกำหนด
metadata ทั้งหมดสำหรับ job ผ่าน
batch script ซึ่งก็แค่ shell script
ที่มี annotation เฉพาะของ Slurm
annotation เหล่านี้ช่วยให้กำหนดความต้องการทรัพยากร
พารามิเตอร์การ schedule และอื่น ๆ ได้
ลองดู submission script กัน
จะเห็นการกำหนด partition
จำนวน node ที่ต้องการ จำนวน task ต่อ node ที่จะ
รัน จำนวน CPU ต่อ task ที่จะใช้
และ script ที่ต้องการรัน
และนี่คือโปรแกรม hello world ของเรา
ในการ submit job ให้รัน ต้องใช้แค่
คำสั่งเดียวคือ sbatch
แล้วระบุ script เป็น argument
เราสามารถดู execution queue
และเห็นว่าโปรแกรม hello world กำลังรันอยู่
บน partition normal บน node c one
เมื่อ job เสร็จแล้ว ก็ดูผลลัพธ์ได้
ผ่านไฟล์ output
เพียงเท่านี้เอง
เราสนใจที่จะใช้ทรัพยากร quantum ด้วย
ดังนั้นมาสร้างโปรแกรม hello Qiskit ง่าย ๆ กัน
นี่คือโปรแกรม Qiskit ของเรา ซึ่งมีขั้นตอน
ครบทุกอย่างตั้งแต่การสร้าง circuit
การ optimize การรัน และการประมวลผลผลลัพธ์
และนี่คือแนวคิดการเขียนโปรแกรมทั้งหมดที่เราพูดถึง
ได้แก่ quantum circuit, transpiler
และ Qiskit primitives
ต่อมาต้องสร้าง submission script
เหมือนเดิม แต่ตรงนี้เราระบุ
ความต้องการทรัพยากร quantum
เมื่อกำหนดทรัพยากรแล้ว
และ partition บน cluster แล้ว
ทรัพยากร quantum ที่มีอยู่
Qiskit primitives จะใช้
ทรัพยากรที่ได้รับจัดสรรในการรัน quantum job
ต่อมาก็รันโปรแกรมของเรา
เมื่อ job เสร็จแล้ว ก็ดูผลลัพธ์ได้
และนี่คือค่า expectation value ของเรา
เพียงเท่านี้สำหรับเรื่องการจัดการทรัพยากร
ในหัวข้อถัดไปเราจะพูดถึง
programming model กัน